مع هدير لمنافسة طائرة عابرة ، فإن
السيكادا في حالة حركة
مجموعة رائعة تسمى الحضنة 10
وعندما يخرج الذكور من
نداء التزاوج ،
هذه ضوضاء الطائرة كنا في
وسط الطريق 10.
لن تسمع هذه الطائرة.
تظهر سلالة معينة في
وسط المحيط الأطلسي وفي بعض ولايات الغرب الأوسط التي
تعيش تحت الأرض على جذور الأشجار
تحسب الدورات الموسمية
لتلك الأشجار وتخرج
إلى الضوء مرة واحدة فقط
كل 17 عامًا لإبهار
علماء الحشرات في المكان المناسب في
الوقت المناسب
مثل فلويد سميثسونيان
حالات الطوارئ الجماعية الدورية من الزيز هي
واحدة من
تلك الأشياء مرة أو مرتين في العمر ،
وآمل أن الأشخاص الذين
تعرفهم ليسوا خائفين ولكن يستمتعون
بالعرض في المناطق المزدحمة
، وقد يظهر مليون ونصف لكل
فدان تريليون في الارتفاع عندما
تصل درجة حرارة التربة إلى 64 درجة ، هل
تعتبر خطيرة كلا على الرغم من أنها يمكن أن
تتلف بعض
الأشجار الصغيرة حيث تضع بيضها هل هي
صالحة للأكل
نعم أوه نعم
هذا هو الصوت الذي تريده  لنسمع أن
هناك مقاطع فيديو عبر الإنترنت تقدم وصفات
مثل هذه من مكتب مزرعة تينيسي ،
إذا كنت تستطيع أن
تتغذى ، فهل أكلت عيني أيضًا قليلًا من المقرمشة ،
إذا
علقت ساق بين أسناني هنا إذا قمت بتوابلهم
بشكل صحيح ، فإن طعمهم يشبه إلى حد كبير الروبيان
لماذا هناك الكثير لأن كل شيء
يأكلهم السيكادا يبقى على قيد الحياة فقط لأن هناك
الكثير مما يجب التهامه تمامًا ،
وسوف يكونون في الجوار لفترة طويلة ، ليس فقط بضعة
أسابيع من
السيكادا الدورية خارجة فقط
كبالغين لهذا الشيء الوحيد وهو
التزاوج ووضع البيض والموت ولكن  هل سيثيرون إزعاجًا لدى
بعض الأشخاص تمامًا
، حتى أن هناك فيلمًا جديدًا هذا الربيع
وقد خمنت أنه يُطلق على الرجال المخيفين
اسم
الزيز الذي لا يُصدق ، لذلك
يقول العلماء إذا وقعت في هذه
العاصفة الزاحفة الزاحفة الزاحفة ،
فلا تفكر في الأمر على أنه مصدر إزعاج مخيف
ولكنه طبيعي
أتساءل مثل جراند كانيون أو شلالات نياجرا
هذا ما يقولون